les fans attendaient son grand retour
depuis des mois ils sont enfin exaucés
j'ai trois bonnes nouvelles à vous
annoncer Céline Dion soeur est de retour
mais un au cinéma 2 pour sa tournée
européenne mais et juin et également
pourquoi pour un nouveau single regardez
le récap et derrière on pourra être
heureux
[Applaudissements]
voilà longtemps que l'on attendait des
nouvelles de Céline Dion sa dernière
apparition publique remontée à avril
dernier où elle annonçait repousser à
nouveau sa tournée européenne je suis
tellement
désolé attristé
d'être obligé de repousser les
spectacles une fois de plus en cause
plusieurs problèmes de santé qui
empêcheraient la chanteuse d'assurer ces
choses
et je reçois des traitements mais j'ai
toujours d'espace musculaire mais c'est
mercredi Céline Dion a surpris tout le
monde en partageant une grande nouvelle
à ses fans Céline jouera aux côtés de
pris un cas Chopra et de Sam heughan en
plus de sortir de la nouvelle musique
pour la comédie romantique love again
qui paraîtra au cinéma le 12 mai pour la
première fois la Québécoise fera ses
débuts au cinéma dans une comédie
romantique intitulée love me again et
dans laquelle Céline jouera son propre
rôle elle a également annoncé qu'elle
dévoilera de nouvelles chansons pour ce
film produit par Sony de bonne augure
pour une reprise de sa carrière et
peut-être de la scène
la diva est attendu en septembre 2023 à
Paris pour 6 dates exceptionnel à la
défense Arena alors Céline Dion à la
conquête d'Hollywood vous étiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
les amis
que j'ai rencontré en perso
anecdote que j'avais trouvé charmant de
vous expliquer à quel point elle était
professionnel parce qu'elle était elle
avait la capacité d'être aussi souriante
d'un coup que dans l'arrivée pleure d'un
moment à un autre pour un moment avec
Maurane et elle croise Maurane dans les
dans les dans les loges et elle dit je
chanterai pas en direct je ne veux pas
et Morane dit si on chantera en direct
et elle dit non je te préviens je
voudrais pas en direct et c'est moi qui
décide et elle arrive en plateau la
musique part et le direct arrive et elle
voit que c'est le direct
elle se met à chanter en direct et elle
tombe dans les bras de morale maman Rams
tellement contente qu'en plus cette
histoire là tu es en direct c'est nous
qu'on chante tout le temps comme ça
et je me suis dit c'est incroyable quoi
vous savez vous n'êtes pas la première
grande star avec elle a parlé parce que
la première grande star avec à la fin
film c'est Peggy la [ __ ] et c'est
dans le oui je vous jure elle a fait un
film à regarder avec le on va en parler
parce que c'est très bon parce qu'elle
dit on se voit au cinéma donc Céline
Dion on dit on se voit au cinéma c'est
ninjora aux côtés de print qui en cas
Chopra pris en cas et ça bugmann en plus
de sortir de la nouvelle musique pour la
commune musicale love again alors
raconte-nous parce que je vois un faux
Déborah c'est quoi ce film en fait c'est
un film qui a adapté d'un film allemand
qui s'appelle SMS von purch c'est
maintenant est bon je crois et en gros
c'est quelqu'un c'est une femme que
c'est une femme qui a perdu son mari et
qui un jour envoie un texto l'ancien
numéro de son de son compagnon qui est
décédé et c'est un autre homme qui a ce
numéro qui vit dans la même ville
qu'elle il tombe amoureux
ils sont fans de Céline Dion et ses
lignes il y a un carton propre rôle
voilà d'accord et donc à la mise en
contact et exactement et du coup elle
sera dans ce film là ça fait très
longtemps parce que la dernière fois
qu'on l'avait vu c'était du coup en 2014
dans le Muppet le fameux je m'appelle
chaud et elle jouera aux côtés de ces
deux grand et les fans en plus on leur a
chance de voir la superstar sur grand
écran et découvriront par la même
occasion un nouveau morceau à interprété
par la chanteuse c'est ça bande
originale c'est la bande originale et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on voit qu'elle
est prochaine donc on peut pas vous le
passer elle va quand même un peu mieux
mais c'est sa sœur Claudette Dion qui la
dernière fois arrête de rire
de Céline en disant qu'il l'avait vu
avec une petite jambe toute tordue
Céline non Claudette
avec une petite jambe toute tordue c'est
ces mots à elle et elle explique qu'à
son avis ça à cause du sol de la du
César Palace
n'est pas pleine parce qu'en fait comme
il y a une espèce de de de
gens sont assis comme ça et pour que tu
as un dégradé merci beaucoup et du coup
la la scène est un petit peu comme ça
donc la pauvre elle est montée comme ça
en permanence et au bout de quelques
oreillette t'imagines elle a fait
pendant 16 ans merci la phlébite au bout
passe sa vie à faire des acrobaties
aussi indépendamment de la scène elle
passe sa vie être comme ça je saurais
pas le faire mais bien sûr bien sûr
c'est quand même une bonne chose qu'elle
fasse ce film parce que je pense que vu
que son état de santé quand même pas
encore extraordinaire un tournage c'est
quand même beaucoup moins fatiguant que
d'être sur scène ça lui permet de
continuer à exister sur sur la scène
internationale avec de grands acteurs
donc franchement c'est une super bonne
idée que j'aime très bonne nouvelle pour
vous donc elle va revenir ça va être
mais ou juin revenir chanter en Europe
il y a un nouvel album qui est en
préparation oui c'était encore un mot
oui non je voulais juste te dire que ce
film faut que tu te gratter les cheveux
il y a un truc
Hugo va me rattraper bientôt hein
juste préciser que le film il a quand
même été tourné en 2020 un bon moment
que la chanson en revanche ça c'est les
infos du Parisien a été enregistré
récemment et il circule que la chanson a
été compliqué à enregistrer et qu'elle
est absolument pas prête en tout cas
aujourd'hui pour monter sur scène bien
sûr donc je réponds à la question
elle elle dit qu'elle était malade à
cause de la salle du César qui est à 8 %
et sa sœur Claudette qui est charmante a
quand même dit pas du tout sponso
l'histoire
de plusieurs symptômes sévères qui sont
liés à la ménopause qui est la cause de
son mallette depuis un an elle a des
grosses douleurs au ventre et également
aux jambes à cause de la ménopause
juin prochain chantier que ça c'est pour
les questions assurance parce que vous
êtes obligé de rembourser si vous
n'aimez pas une nouvelle date dans un
délai raisonnable
[Musique]
mais ceux qui ne